[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen hier sind Toni und heute
mal nicht Mirko sondern Stefan yes wir
sind heute Premiere das erste Mal
zusammen hier im Studio wir haben
festgestellt dass wir noch nie einen
Fall zusammen aufgenommen haben werden
wir auch heute nicht tun
aber eigentlich wollten wir euch
mitteilen dass wir nach dem dunklen
Januar der ja hier dieses daily Format
ins Rollen gebracht hat wir sind schon
im sechsten Monat von Tatort Deutschland
kommt jetzt erstmal eine Art Pause dazu
gleich mehr aber wir wollen auch ein
bisschen zurückblicken also wenn man
genau guckt wir haben ernsthaft jetzt
157 folgen in diesem Channel und ich
habe so ein paar Fragen aufgeschrieben
Toni weil wir jetzt einfach so eine Art
verbrechensexperten geworden sind
überall die Monate zum Beispiel Frage an
dich Toni was war der Fall der bei dir
am tollsten hängen geblieben ist das ist
eine schwierige Frage weil nicht der
Fall irgendwie hängen bleibt
es gibt aber zwei Fälle die ich ganz
besonders krass fand einmal war das
Irina u die Folge heißt die Knochen im
Müll könnt ihr auch hier im Feed einmal
danach suchen da hatte der Mann seine
Frau als vermisst gemeldet und später
hat sich rausgestellt dass er sie
umgebracht hat sie auf einer Mülldeponie
abgeladen hat und zeitgleich mit seiner
Affäre geschrieben hatte ihr auch also
der Affäre die Halskette seiner Frau die
er umgebracht hat geschenkt hat das
waren so viele Details die auch bei der
Recherche da hochkam ich einfach dachte
wie wie krank können Menschen sein oder
eiskalt das ist auf jeden Fall hängen
geblieben fand ich sehr sehr
schockierend und der andere ist du wirst
es wahrscheinlich an Tiger Adams hatten
wir erst hier vor kurzem den kenne ich
seit Jahren habe ich den zum ersten Mal
in einem anderen Podcast gehört und
seitdem hat er mich gefesselt weil ich
den so auf der einen ist es eine
heldenstory weil ich diese Frau wirklich
bedruckend finde was für eine Stärke und
überlebenswellen die hat und auch wie
sie mit der Sache im Nachhinein umgeht
aber ist natürlich die Vorstellung ist
so brutal für mich ja das konnte ich
nicht mehr vergessen dazu zwei
schlüssellochblicke das war das erste
Skript dass du geschrieben hast wir
haben sonst so eine Arbeitsaufteilung
hast du auch sehr gut geschrieben und
dann wollte das Timing das aber
ausgegangen dass ich das dann gesprochen
habe das hat mir auch ein bisschen leid
weil es war ja auch ein bisschen so dir
von von der Leidenschaft hier auf dem
Leib geschrieben
diese Geschichte zu erzählen und wer sie
dann am Ende euch den Hörern präsentiert
das machen ja alle gleich gut also bei
mir war es dieser barschel-fall die
Folge das ist eine Doppelfolge gewesen
Endstation genießt die weil erstens die
habe ich geschrieben und gesprochen mit
Mirko weil das eben alles in der Stadt
spielt aus der ich komme und ich habe
darin noch mal Dinge entdeckt die ich
zwischendurch schon wieder vergessen
hatte also das z.B dieser Politiker
erstens an der Schule auf der ich auch
war dieses Skandal hatte wusste ich noch
dann die ganze politaffäre aber das ja
zum Beispiel kurz vorher auch noch mit
dem Flugzeug abgestürzt ist da habe ich
gedacht so beim Schreiben wie ihre ist
das eigentlich wenn das Skript von mir
Fiction wäre hätte jemand gesagt der
Netze Band hat völlig übertrieben also
das hat mich sehr beeindruckt Toni mit
welchen Menschen hast du dich besonders
identifiziert bei all diesen Fällen ist
natürlich eine komische Frage also mit
den Tätern identifiziere ich mich jetzt
persönlich weniger ja tatsächlich ich
will hier nicht langweilig sein aber TK
Adams war nicht einfach von der Stärke
her konnte ich schon nachvollziehen wie
sie dann auch am Ende sagt trotz allem
bin ich super happy mit meinem Kind und
das alles hat mich nur noch stärker
gemacht und ich glaube das war so das
warum mich dieser Fall auch fesselt weil
ich glaube ich auch ein Mensch bin der
aus einem negativen immer irgendwie was
positives noch zieht ja ja so nehme ich
dich auch danke bei mir war das der Fall
mit Ingrid van Bergen wer ihn nach hören
will die schöne und der Mord weil
ja einmal wegen der Schönheit natürlich
ich meine es ist in unserer Reihe und an
morgen insgesamt faszinierend wie
sozusagen Menschen die heute noch normal
erscheinen eigentlich morgen Mörder sind
das ist aber ganz vielen Fällen so und
bei ihr fand ich das schon krass also
ich will nicht sagen dass ich mich
direkt mit ihr identifiziere aber die
war sozusagen in Zeiten wo das keine
Selbstverständlichkeit war schon eine
Powerfrau die ihr Ding durchgezogen hat
in so einer Männerwelt und dann eben von
dem Typen völlig abgefuckt war der sie
eigentlich nur verarscht hat ja und dann
ist sie halt die Sicherung durchgebrannt
das ist im Unterschied zu vielen Sagen
immer so Serienmördern und Leuten die
andere gerne quälen ist das eine Sache
da kann ich mich am ehesten noch ein
Stück weit reinversetzen
auch die letzten Monate super viele
Skripte geschrieben hat sich da
irgendwie was bei dir verändert so die
Art wie du auf das Produkt auf solche
Fälle ich glaube dass ich meine Sicht
auf Menschen sich tatsächlich ein
bisschen verändert hat ich verstehe
jetzt auch so User von Podcast dass die
eigentlich immer ein Interesse daran
haben an welche Grenzen wir Menschen
stoßen bei wem welcher Punkt verletzt
wird ich sitze noch öfter zu Hause und
sagt zu meiner Frau online du glaubst es
nicht jetzt hat er das und das gemacht
oder so da habe ich mich tatsächlich
vorher nicht so sehr mit beschäftigt das
hat mich schon so ein bisschen
hellhöriger gemacht für die
Schattenseiten des des Menschen ja auf
jeden Fall ja dann haben wir uns fragen
wollen auch noch mal für dich welcher
Fall oder welche Art von Fällen deine
Sichtweise verändert hat seit wir das
machen vielleicht
alle ein bisschen weil ich das Gefühl
habe ich bin
fast ein bisschen paranoid geworden es
ist manchmal so dass ich in so random
Situationen zum Beispiel beim Bäcker mir
irgendwie was hole oder Kaugummi kaufe
gucke ich so auf die Uhr und denke mir
ah jetzt ist es 15:12 Uhr für mein Alibi
es ist total bescheuert aber ich denke
mir auch durch diese ganzen Fälle die
wir auch hatten
da fühle ich mich auch manchmal sicher
weil ich so denke wenn mir jetzt
irgendwas passieren würde dann wüsste
ich vielleicht schon eher was so
Warnzeichen werden worauf ich achten
muss wie ich dann vielleicht doch noch
aus so einer Situation rauskomme also ja
so live survival Training ja also ich
fand an der Reihe auch noch mal spannend
zu merken gerade Überfällen die zum
Beispiel jetzt im deutschen Kaiserreich
spielen und so wie beschissen früher
ermittelt wurde das war eine einzige
Schlamperei da war zum Teil in keiner
zuständig oder jemand dachte
irgendjemand ist schuld und dann wird
das irgendwie so gemacht also viel
Urteile in Reihe und du warst echt also
gerade wenn du dann auch noch arm warst
z.B oder so als Opfer dann würdest du
zum Teil auch einfach gar nicht vermisst
also bei allem was man heute meckert an
der Zeit oder überwachungsstart oder dem
Stadt insgesamt ich finde ein
Menschenleben ist heutzutage schon ganz
schön viel wert früher ja
Toni was findest du jetzt nach einem
halben Jahr was sollten wir anders
machen oder mehr machen oder weniger
machen
mehr könnten wir vielleicht eure
Community Vorschläge machen also immer
gerne her damit zum Beispiel per Mail
oder Instagram das verlinken wir euch
auch in den Show Notes wie immer das
finde ich richtig cool wenn wir davon
mehr machen würden ich hätte auch so
blöd das klingt aber mal wieder Lust auf
so einen Kannibalen Fall
abartig aber meist steckt dahinter ja so
eine ganz tragische Geschichte und das
finde ich immer interessant bei den
Fällen das eigentlich von vornherein man
hört so grob was passiert ist und denkt
sich ja ist ja klar ist einfach ein
Monster aber das halt so einfach da
hätte ich auf jeden Fall Lust drauf mich
da auch so ein bisschen mehr wieder mit
auseinanderzusetzen gerade vielleicht
auch zu gucken ob es da irgendwo
Zusammenhänge gibt wieso muss da
sozusagen ja aber anders würde ich jetzt
gar nicht so viel machen ich finde das
richtig toll also ich finde wir haben
die Folgen gut gefallen wo Kollegen
erzählen welche Fälle sie bearbeiten das
ist auch schon mehr geworden und ich
finde das können wir ja nach der
Sommerpause noch mehr auf jeden Fall
Leute drin wie Lena Zander Frank
Schneider wir hatten jetzt einen Fall
z.B mit Walter Straten der ist
eigentlich Sportchef bei uns
politisch Fälle auch spannend finde also
der Kollegenkreis wächst und ich glaube
wir können versprechen dass da noch mehr
kommt was
gut dann geht es jetzt für uns ein
bisschen in die Ferien für euch
hoffentlich auch wir bereiten vor ihr
habt es gerade gehört im August geht es
dann weiter ne genau aber vorher machen
wir im Juli wöchentlich Wii Uploads mit
jeweils zwei guten Fällen die thematisch
auch so ein bisschen zusammengehören und
außerdem gibt es dann in der letzten
Juliwoche einen Fall wo an Jahrestag
ansteht also dazu produzieren wir eine
neue Doppelfolge und ansonsten gibt es
jetzt im Juli so eine Art best of und
wir hoffen ihr seid da dabei und ihr
seid weiter dabei genau lasst es euch
gut gehen und bis dann